[Música]
bom
levanta a mão aqui quem tá super
satisfeito com a sua relação com o
dinheiro e poucos é esse mesmo pessoal
ea gente veio aqui falar sobre dinheiro
não sobre como ficar rico e muito menos
para dizer pra vocês que se o pote de
ouro não caiu na sua frente até hoje foi
por que você não deseja o suficiente
a gente sabe que dinheiro tem diversas
questões estruturais sistêmicas e
sociais envolvidas e que é algo que a
gente tem que aprender a lidar um pouco
melhor como sociedade né
mas a gente sabe também que enquanto a
gente não olhar pra dentro em como cada
um de nós de ida com isso dificilmente a
gente vai ter a vontade coletiva para em
direção a esse mundo mais justo que
todos nós queremos é verdade
sempre tem alguma coisa para a gente
aprender sobre nós mesmos quando a gente
olha para a nossa relação com o dinheiro
eu por exemplo era esse tipo de pessoa
que sempre achava que não tinha dinheiro
pra nada e depois né eu fui perceber só
então eu fui perceber que na verdade o
que acontecia era que eu gostava tanto
do que eu fazia que eu achava que não
precisava ganhar dinheiro e também não
controlava muito as minhas finanças ou
seja o buraco é bem mais embaixo
já eu era essa pessoa que achava que
tinha que acumula uma boa quantia para
me sentir segura e aí sim e descobriu
que eu gostava porque é bem diferente da
time e é interessante justamente a gente
olhar essa diversidade de pontos de
vista
por que a gente é capaz de aprender com
essas diferentes histórias e aí que tal
se a gente começar a contar nossa
história boa bom quando eu era criança
eu adorava histórias a minha vida 1 com
de fadas já no meu caso eu adorava
investigar o funcionamento das coisas de
calcular matemática na minha matéria
preferida na minha infância também
lembro dos meus pais trabalhando muito
duro para conseguir pagar todas as
contas de casa
eles casaram cedo engravidaram cedo e
não tinham se formado ainda
ou seja eles tiveram que na surpresa
entrar em qualquer emprego para poder
conseguir pagar todas as contas e isso
eu me fez ter uma recordação de muita
frustração do meu pai porque no fundo o
que ele queria mesmo era ser jogador de
futebol
já minha memória era que meus pais
trabalhavam bastante também
mas até que isso parecia bastante
divertido eu adorava acompanhar
inclusive a rotina matinal deles ficava
com meu pai às vezes na frente do
espelho pedindo para ele me ensinar a
fazer nó na gravata e quando ele tinha
trabalho para fazer em casa eu sentava
do lado dele e imitava o jeito de ele
escrever pegava uma calculadora brincava
com ela essas coisas que a criança faz
ou na adolescência eu tive uma paixão o
teatro eu adorava subir no palco e
contar histórias e graças a deus meus
pais eles me incentivavam muito nessa
carreira ele eles diziam você pode não
vir a ser uma fernanda montenegro nem
ser tão famosa nem ganhar tanto dinheiro
contanto que você siga o seu sonho
bom eu acabei não sendo a 3 foi fazer
produção cultural na faculdade mas já no
primeiro período eu e criei uma
produtora independente comecei a fazer
vários shows peças de teatro enfim
trabalho era o que não faltava
mas dinheiro que é bom nada já minha
adolescência ela foi marcada por uma
longa crise financeira economizar é o
lema em casa e dinheiro parecia
restrição para tudo a gente inclusive
teve que se mudar algumas vezes e parece
que toda permanência cá a nossa
permanência em cada lugar
ela sempre depende da nossa capacidade
de economizar e do nosso esforço de
juntar dinheiro e cada vez mais
a coisa foi marcando não importa muito
que eu vou escolher de profissão o que
importa é que essa profissão me de
dinheiro e aí na época de vestibular
eu queria mesmo era ter feito filosofia
mas isso não parecia muito dinheiro na
época e aí eu fui fazer economia
afinal onde está o dinheiro né gente eo
interessante é que no primeiro ano da
faculdade eu já estava estagiando
e embora não esteja não estivesse sendo
muito bem remunerada ainda só o fato de
eu saber que eu estava investindo meu
tempo numa carreira que fosse me dar
estabilidade no longo prazo já era
suficiente para me deixará plenamente
satisfeita bom profissionalmente eu fui
trabalhar numa grande empresa com
eventos e comunicação comunidade
ela era tão grande tão grande que eu me
senti um peixe fora d'água ali no meio
daqueles diretores que pareciam que só
queriam diminuir os custos e aumentar os
ganhos aumentar os lucros é e aí eu mas
eu pensava é uma boa oportunidade de eu
fazer alguma coisa bacana e com o
dinheiro dos outros
enfim fiquei lá e foi um momento em que
eu comecei a ganhar relativamente bem
consegui sair da casa dos meus pais e
finalmente comecei a viajar por esse
mundão coisa que eu nunca achei que
fosse conseguir de vida a realidade da
minha família e eu me tornei funcionária
pública agora estava bem remunerada e
tinha estabilidade no emprego ou seja
parecia que todos os meus problemas
tinham se acabado e finalmente podia
correr atrás da tal felicidade e eu devo
confessar que isso deu certo por um
tempo mas passaram alguns anos e alguma
coisa foi parando de fazer sentido
eu gostava do meu trabalho eu gostava
das pessoas mas eu não sei eu comecei a
sentir necessidade de experimentar
coisas diferentes é depois de cinco anos
nessa grande empresa eu também comecei a
ficar cheia de dúvidas já não acreditava
que dá
ia pra fazer realmente alguma coisa tão
legal para a sociedade e também enfim é
o salário ele já não dava assim ele era
razoável mas ele não conseguirá cobrir
todas as minhas compensações né porque
também eu trabalhava tanto eu me
estressava tanto que eu achava que assim
eu podia na minha cabeça tomar um chope
na hora que eu quisesse comprar as
roupas que eu quisesse
enfim está com que eu quisesse bom
a empresa graças a deus entrou em crise
quando eu já estava em crise faz tempo o
que facilitou o meu processo de pra ser
emitida e depois de um tempo fora dessa
empresa eu comecei a conhecer pessoas
que já estavam trabalhando de forma
diferentes
foi quando eu ouvi falar de
sustentabilidade novas economias é as
pessoas estavam trabalhando em rede e
metodologias colaborativa eu achei
aquilo tudo tão fascinante que eu
resolvi enfim me jogar de cabeça e
começar a trabalhar dessa forma também é
eu demorei um pouquinho para chegar aí e
até porque minhas referências na época
que eu estava naquela crise né
eram de pessoas que saíam dos seus
empregos pra fazer uma grande viagem ou
então para se mudar para o interior
achava isso legal pra elas podia ser
interessante mas não sei é que eu não
reverberava pra mim eu senti que eu
queria ficar fazer alguma coisa aqui e
mesmo não sabendo muito bem por onde
começar ainda assim eu decidi me afastar
do meu emprego e buscar outras
experiências
aquele meu padrão de economizar
economizar economizar na verdade foi o
que me ajudou ali porque eu tinha
conseguido juntar a maior parte dos meus
salários e quando bateu essa crise
eu vi que eu tinha recursos para
finalmente me deixar e atrás dessa
exploração do que eu achava que fazia
sentido pra mim é um detalhe tão
importante que é totalmente o oposto de
mim eu te admiro tanto gostam disso
porque eu nunca conseguir acumular
minimamente um dinheiro então conta que
um pouquinho pra
gente sobre esse processo então como eu
falei eu não sabia nem por onde começar
e então foi super confuso super dispersa
eu comecei a atirar pra tudo quanto é
canto
então no início eu criei um site de
meditação
eu comecei a estudar a terapias fui
buscar experiências espirituais mas aí
eu comecei a me sentir muito sozinho
aí resolvi fazer alguns trabalhos
voluntários
fiz algumas viagens e inclusive fui
fazer outra faculdade
e aí realmente as coisas começaram a se
encaixar mas ainda assim eu sentir que
algo me faltava e quando eu percebi esse
algo que me faltava era justamente a
inspiração não estava faltando dinheiro
mas que estava voltando de inspiração e
acho que com você foi bem o contrário né
verdade eu empreendedora nata
eu tinha um monte de projeto um monte de
idéia mas não tinha um centavo para
realizá las
engraçado que nessa época eu achava que
o meu maior desafio era só conseguir
realizar esses projetos e não precisava
voltar para o mundo corporativo só pra
pagar as minhas contas
mal sabia eu que o desafio só estava
começando um como assim porque eu não
parava de trabalhar mesmo fora no mundo
corporativo eu trabalhava 24 horas por
dia porque eu queria tanto que os
projetos com o propósito enfim virassem
realidade que eu não parava e ainda pior
eu estava tão feliz de fazer o que eu
gostava que eu não precisava ganhar
dinheiro ou seja isso não era
sustentável nem pra minha vida nem pro
meu bolso é porque não dá pra viver de
luz
enfim bom para melhorar a situação eu
encontrei duas amigas minhas que me
disseram que iam fazer uma imersão é
sobre negócios sociais e em bangladesh
eu já tinha lido o livro do roma de
unidos sobre negócios sociais e desde
então eu comecei a sonhar em fazer essa
imersão
mas como era em bangladesh ea mulher eu
nunca tive coragem de ir sozinho
logo quando eu conheço quando o encontro
duas pessoas que estão indo eu não tinha
nenhum dinheiro para poder fazer essa
viagem então eu achei no começo que era
um sinal divino de que eu tinha que
abrir mão desse sonho e esse sonho não
era pra mim mas depois de um tempo não
até uns amigos meus disseram taiana você
está trabalhando com novas economias com
o mundo colaborativo
será que não há oportunidade de agora
você experimentar na sua vida algo né
alguma ferramenta nesse sentido e foi aí
que resolvi fazer um financiamento
coletivo para poder viabilizar essa
imersão que bacana pois é eu acho que a
gente já se conhecia nessa época eu
lembro bem mas acho que seria bacana se
você comentasse um pouco mais com
pessoal como é que foi todo esse
processo é verdade porque assim
financiamento coletivo ao contrário do
que as pessoas acham que é um processo
muito mais interno do que externo porque
você tem que ter coragem imagina de
ficar pedindo ajuda para todos todas as
pessoas que você conhece todos os seus
amigos para realizar um projeto que é
seu e é tão difícil pedir ajuda né
quanto mais e de dinheiro bom é graças a
deus a campanha foi bem sucedida eu fui
fazer a imersão
só que quando eu voltei eu voltei
completamente sem grana sem dinheiro
nenhum e o pior
eu comecei a perceber que na verdade eu
mesmo não sabia cuidar do meu dinheiro o
que foi um processo muito doloroso eu
comecei a ficar com muita vergonha logo
eu que trabalhava com novas economias
falava de dinheiro não tinha dinheiro
não sabia cuidar de mim e pra tentar
resolver eu comecei a fazer mais
trabalho e entrei no processo de
trabalhar trabalhar até que as contas só
aumentavam o trabalho só aumentava e não
adiantava foi um processo assim muito
difícil eu fiquei muito envergonhada me
senti muito sozinha pois é eu super team
tendo eu também estava me sentindo muito
sozinha e eu acho que demorei muito
tempo para reconhecer o quanto eu
precisava de ajuda mas principalmente de
apoio de parceiros
dias de pessoas que pudessem pensar
junto comigo eu acho que ao longo da
minha história foi se formando essa
imagem na minha cabeça de que a vida em
sociedade é uma coisa cada um no seu
quadrado
ou seja tinha que aprender a lidar com
tudo sozinha e que pedir ajuda a uma
espécie de sinal de fraqueza ou fracasso
eu tinha que aprender a lidar com meu
dinheiro sozinha eu tinha que resolver
todos os meus problemas sozinho
e foi aí que eu comecei a conhecer
pessoas que também estavam questionando
esses valores e tentando experimentar
uma vida mais em comunidade um pouco de
tempo depois eu fui morar num numa
moradia compartilhada e e também
experimentar trabalhar em coletivos que
são organizações mais horizontais e com
mais autonomia e aí que vieram os
desafios porque eu comecei a sentir meus
espaços sendo invadidos
eu comecei a sentir as necessidades de
minha sendo atropeladas e como se não
bastasse sempre vi uma moça uma voz
interna superset que dizendo que essa
história de colaboração vai fazer todo
mundo morrer de fome e ficar sem
dinheiro ou seja tudo começou a gritar
dentro de mim é muito doido como é
difícil sair dessa
nesse mundinho individualista né verdade
eu acho que foi isso amiga que começou a
nos aproximar essas trocas do que a
gente estava vivendo porque eu estava
nesse processo de não ter dinheiro e não
querer parar de trabalhar com projetos
que teórica davam dinheiro e você já
tinha dinheiro queria começar a
experimentar a colaborar compartilhar
mas enfrentando as suas próprias
barreiras pois é interessante de
percebeu como as nossas diferenças se
complementavam porque a verdade é que a
gente podia continuar aqui cada um no
seu quadrado eu achando que a taxa está
completamente errada pelo comportamento
dela e ela achando que eu estou errada
só que a gente conseguiu sair disso e
perceber que a gente pode aprender com
as diferenças e também se inspirar com
elas
e foi aí que a gente
e decidiu transbordar isso também para
trabalhos em grupo abrindo espaço de
confiança para que outras pessoas
pudessem também pesquisar as suas
próprias relações com dinheiro e se
inspirar com os diferentes pontos de
vista que tem no grupo é e eu por
exemplo eu descobri que guardar dinheiro
também pode ser auto cuidado
parece brincadeira mas só trocando com
as pessoas foi que realmente sentir que
como diz aquela frase entre juntar
dinheiro e trabalhar com o propósito eu
mereço eu posso escolher os dois porque
só eu cuidando de mim mesma é que eu
consiga exercer a minha potência e
consigo transformar o mundo do jeito que
eu acredito e eu confirmei que
relacionamento com dinheiro não se trata
só de controle financeiro individual
antigamente eu julgava muitas pessoas
que não conseguiam reter dinheiro como
se elas fossem controladas e
responsáveis
ou seja se uma pessoa ficar sem dinheiro
o problema era dela e ponto final eu não
tinha nada a ver com isso ela que tinha
sido responsável né
e aí depois eu comecei a perceber que
era justamente esses julgamentos que me
zoavam nesse meu mundinho individualista
e que eu podia escolher sair desse
mundinho
quando eu decidi a apoiá las e quando eu
tomar essa decisão
eu percebia que não era só eu que estava
sendo que não só não era só eu estava
ajudando eu também estava recebendo
muita coisa delas e é esses são dois
exemplos de todas as descobertas e curas
que estão acontecendo nesses grupos de
aprendizagem e também no estadão que a
gente tem compartilhado várias histórias
porque não se trata só de dinheiro
não sei se vocês repararam mas a questão
é que o dinheiro faz a gente realmente
ver e perceber como é que a gente
interage com o mundo olhando para o
dinheiro eu começo a ter mais
consciência dos meus hábitos de consumo
das minhas necessidades ou do que eu
achava que eram as minhas necessidades
né da minha relação com
trabalho enfim eu começo a realmente
perceber o que eu estou priorizando na
minha vida e falar sobre dinheiro também
ajuda a gente a perceber que a gente não
está sozinho nessa caminho nessa
caminhada e que a gente pode se inspirar
com as histórias dos outros e com as
diferenças e só assim a gente pode ver
em em comunidade é com unidade verdade e
como diz um ditado se você quiser ir
rápido vá sozinho e se você quiser ir
longe
vamos juntas
[Aplausos]